merkels politik ist ein wrack um die
stimmung im land rumzureißen müssen wir
endlich schluss machen mit dem fetisch
schwarze null
mit den steuer überschüssen im großen
stil bezahlbaren wohnraum schaffen wir
freude
wir bräuchten einen handlungsfähigen
staat der sich wieder zuständig fühlt
für die soziale infrastruktur der sich
nicht damit abfinden dass zum beispiel
weite teile des ruhrgebiets aussehen wie
rumänien und der verdammt noch mal
aufhören jobs von denen man nicht leben
kann als arbeitsplätze zu zählen
oliver wickel hielt ein völlig sinnloses
und und lustiges plädoyer für mehr
soziale gerechtigkeit wird nie wieder
vorkommen